-Guys, it is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing
every week,
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So, since a lot of schools
are on spring break,
I sent out the hashtag
#SpringBreakInSixWords."
And I asked you
to describe your spring break
using only six words.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic.
So thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite responses
from you guys.
This first one
is from @heartyou4evr.
-Hmm.
-She says, "Shots!
Don't remember much after that."
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one is from
@roadninjakelly.
-Ooh.
-She says, "Parents
saw me on the news."
Oh, there you go. Hey
[ Laughter and applause ]
At least they know
where you are.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ]
This one's from @joybur10.
She says, "Kiss me,
I still have antibodies."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just got back.
This one's from @K8MBrown.
She says,
"Going topless this year.
No mask!"
-Ah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's weird.
I like it, though.
It's from @Kansasbradbury.
-Oh.
-He says, "Nobody
puts Baby in a cabana."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I saw that.
I don't know why I like that.
"Nobody puts Baby
in the cabana."
Come.
-A little "Dirty Dancing."
-This one's from @acnirb.
-Nirb.
-He says, "What shall we
name the kid?"
Oh.
-Oh, wow.
Got deep fast.
[ Rim shot ]
-What shall we?
-What shall we name our child?
-Hmm. Alright.
This is "Spring Break
in Six Words."
This is from @Billyclubbin.
-Well, he's got to have
a good one, right?
He's clubbing 24/7.
-You think Billyclubbin --
he's clubbing -- 24/6?
-He's clubbing all the time,
yeah.
24/6, takes one day off.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh, you have to.
I mean, if you work that hard --
you club that hard?
-Yeah. You club that hard --
-You can't club that hard.
You got to take one day off.
-You got to take it off
in real life.
You've got to reclub yourself.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What time does he start
clubbing, do you think?
-I would say probably, uh, noon.
[ Laughter ]
-He clubs from noon --
-Till noon.
-Every day, for six days.
-24 hours of clubbing.
-Yeah.
Yep, and the one day off,
he has till noon.
And then
he starts clubbing again.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a tough life.
But he says, uh,
"Denial, anger, bargaining,
depression, acceptance, fun!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's like the six stages
of spring break.
I love it.
This is from @optimist-eeyore.
She says, "Wine cheaper
than fuel, let's party!"
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This last one's good.
It's from @dianebillas.
She says, "We don't talk
about...spring break."
There you go, everybody.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.